there are certain plays that will
forever echo through the annals of
Competitive Gaming but you know this
because we put them in literally all of
our videos the Daigo Perry the Edward
pistol Ace the Roshan bait the faker you
outplay there is no shortage of era
defining dumbstrings out there
[Applause]
but it isn't just the competitors we
need to thank for putting on these
insane displays it's the casters the
crowds the POG Champs in chat and of
course the literal Spectators of such
awe-inspiring Ownage The Observers hello
right so he's gonna try and do this
round oh blindfolded using only the
hints that we give him that's how he's
gonna observe this this is a true test
of his observing might observing is
undoubtedly one of the most crucial and
unforgiving jobs in Esports it's also
one of the most thankless the best
observers are the ones who go totally
unnoticed because when you do notice
them
it's usually not a good thing it's on
Plateau right now with that awp could we
go to him please there's a fight on
Plateau right now
B site plateau
oh maybe the Observer broke maybe maybe
something went wrong so Inglorious as
they are great observers can be hard to
come by yeah how many dollar games have
we done I think we would uh average a
thousand to 1200 games a year yeah
something like that sounds reasonable so
time seven yeah quite quite a few games
at this point not only is my observing
pretty good but I work well with the
production because you need to have
communication with the director the
producer uh the replay operator even the
game admin sometimes but what if I told
you that one of counter-strike's most is
steamed observers became famous
for missing the game's craziest play
this mix let's see double smokes in the
same place there simple just jumping
casually to the side he's gonna fall
down
and keep going through that simple
that's not allowed this is not FPL this
is a major I just wish we could see that
one with two live from your POV yeah
meet David Prius Kuntz the Cs Go slash
valorent Observer who in spite of being
among the most experienced and respected
observers in his scenes of choice is
known for one thing and one thing only
getting memed into Oblivion for missing
simples Infamous 1v2 I get everywhere
and it's like in like Valor lobbies for
like pro games for like everywhere for
you know when I'm playing MMS the Boston
versus what we do I'm like dude I can't
escape this so how did music play a role
in prius's rise to prominence how is it
that he managed to execute a 1vx on a
major stage despite being unable to
observe one and why is he getting
ruthlessly made fun of for missing a
play that he didn't actually miss I'll
be honest it wasn't me observing so yeah
the simple play was not me
okay so before we start memeing on Prius
I have to tell you about Opera GX and I
have to I mean like they're they're
making me seriously the sales team made
me switch off of Chrome
the thing is Opera GX kind of slaps it
has Integrations for both twitch and
Discord a built-in music player pop-out
videos and just like a zillion tiny
little time-saving features that give me
more time to focus on what's important I
have recouped precious minutes thanks to
Opera GX
literally
did the math I saved like four and a
half min
now that I don't have to swap Windows to
change tracks check DMS or engage in
meaningful thought-provoking discussions
about the current state of Esports in my
favorite streamers twitch chats stop
plugging your own goddamn videos you
sick son of a we're talking
1624 minutes and 30 seconds across an
entire year which translates to over 27
hours of extra time to get farmed by
opting novas and retakes or encourage my
teammates to turn their monitors on in
League of Legends is world class ranked
experience so go download Opera GX and
shout out to them
for
saving me time all right now despite
being a true OG like a lot of North
America's Finest Counter-Strike
constituents Prius came up on that silly
scrub-tastic sequel known as Source I
was unfortunately a source player a
source kid I guess I found kind of
strike through my brother had my own
surf server 24 7 Skyworld I believe I
started dabbling with servers I was like
oh this is this is cool I can have my
own community and I moved past that
phase I was like you know 12 13 years
old I was like this is this is you know
not not for me from there Prius joined a
jailbreak Community known as hell's
Gamers
okay
you shut up shut up
I basically got into like 10 bands with
Community it was interesting we were all
like very average some people like me
were just a bit above average I guess at
the gate and most of the you know people
are playing with were like you know just
like jailbreak kids that were very bad
and so I started getting into the more
competitive side of Counter-Strike
source and then I found esca here's the
thing though Prius didn't just get into
Counter-Strike because of his eventual
affiliation with esea it was also
because of his
feral Fierce undying hatred for League
of Legends the community maybe play
League of Legends I I just I just didn't
like it I think it was the worst game
ever I just despised it but I had to
learn it because it was like most
popular Esports I started volunteering
for this organization called leaguepedia
and they needed it like a streamer for
their best driven any tournament I have
a screenshot as like 90 000 viewers just
watching my screens with auto director
and League of Legends and then I was
like wow that's awesome just seeing like
seeing the chat have it react to
everything you do was fantastic and I
was like Oh and it lit up like you know
an idea I was like dude this is this is
awesome I love this now as fate would
have it Prius had just started working
as an admin for ESL pro league I was
lead admin for a clone qualifier
throughout the event I was getting
yelled at by the director because you
know the players went ready uh the
player started early
and I was like this is this is too
stressful for me
and so like it was like one of the late
nights uh the Advent table was right
next to the Observer table and Heather
Sapphire was there at the time I was
like Heather you mind if I observe you
know just one map just I just I just
want to try it you know land see if the
casters notice at all see if anything
changes
and uh she's like sure from there things
moved quickly he started observing
online matches for ESL and despite doing
it at night for admittedly meager
amounts quickly caught the attention of
the community how you might ask
music I started playing music in the
pre-game and I started syncing it uh to
the movement of my camera just pre-game
you know that's it and you know that got
a bunch of right of threads daily
Prius started spectating more and more
matches and alongside his friend and
Mentor Sapphire quickly established
himself as one of Cs Go's go-to
observers and at the ESL cologne major
in 2016 Prius got his first shot at
observing an international land now as
many of you are probably aware this
particular major is home to one famously
e-reproducible play about Midway through
team liquid's quarter-final bout against
fnatic our Lord and savior simple found
himself in a pretty hairy 1v2 what
ensued has literally become the stuff of
Legend
see a double smokes in the same place
there simple just jumping casually into
the side he's gonna fall down again
said boy are you serious what is that
you can't do that simple that's not
allowed it's not FPL it's
now if you have somehow never witnessed
the full Majesty of this shellacking you
might actually be thinking to yourself
all right well that was super sick but
not super out of the ordinary right like
he opt two dudes
that's that's what most of us thought
until we saw it from simple's POV
it's simple I don't know man if he comes
in with that
CS go fans didn't know it until they saw
the replay but they had just been
deprived of seeing one of the greatest
plays in the history of their Esports
unfold live naturally people went in on
the observing which really sucked
considering that on the whole Prius and
Sapphire's performance was widely
heralded as world class after clone we
were sitting on the planet me and
Heather going back to Atlanta for illig
and there was like five Reddit threads
on the front page Prius and Sapphire are
worth related gold you know all these
Reddit threads that were just gassing us
up and you know it felt good to know
that people understand what observing is
and appreciate observing when it's good
when it's bad
and that was a cool feeling now for a
long time the community just stuck to
occasionally offhandedly shaking their
head at the tragedy that was the Mist
1v2 but I think it's fair to say that
they didn't put a ton of thought into it
Prius went on to enjoy an illustrious
career becoming an indispensable part of
Cs go observing's go-to dynamic duo and
cementing himself as an adored member of
the Counter-Strike community
continuing the strong form Kenny s fits
one of the final Nails in the coffin now
Prius you called him out as a handy
player can he get anything done
[Applause]
unbelievable scenes have you ever seen
anything like him can someone be the
most simultaneously interesting and
boring person that you've ever met
oh my God okay that's actually not bad
yeah you know oh my God
oh that you know that kid has like a
crazy Dad it's just pushing way too hard
it wasn't until several years later that
a certain someone decided to rear that
tragedy's ugly head once more and what's
more put a face to it and that someone
wasn't a competitor wasn't a Caster
wasn't even a content creator
it was a poster
scratch that
the poster I just remembered Don
Hasty just tweeting at me saying I
wonder what the Observer is doing who
missed this it won't be too and then you
know him and I have been you know go
back and forth I make fun of his you
know his gold coins or silver coins and
then you know he he fought back and
started memeing about yeah I missed it
to say that the meme caught on like
wildfire
would actually be sort of an
understatement
it went ballistic in no time at all
Prius couldn't show his proverbial face
anywhere on streams servers or social
media without getting roasted ratioed
and everything in between when I respond
to someone there if they just run civil
won't let me do or like when I'm in
twitch chat you know someone will
tweeted me or someone will you know at
Prius you know simple me too like I get
everywhere and it's like in like Valor
lobbies for like pro games for like
everywhere for you know when I'm playing
MMS the blossomness isn't moving too I'm
like dude I can't escape this it even
got to the point where the official CS
go Twitter account started publicly
rinsing our boy on the timeline I'm
still on the impression that someone
brought that account that is within the
community it's like Don Hussey you know
probably running the account or
something like that it's or he sends
them tweets right like a thousand you
know reply to this you know for the
memes but the Cisco Twitter account guy
is is hilarious and he knows the
community pretty well and it's pretty
awesome uh getting meme done by the
official Game's Twitter account but the
worst of it was when they mentioned
prius's name to the goat himself ESL did
an interview that's simple for 11 20 22.
and Yanko brought up that yeah man Prius
mistress 1v2 and simple just freaking
had to look at the straw and sadness I
just wish we could see that one with two
live from your POV
yeah
but man now this guy believes it was me
too it's just like come on man wait what
is
what do you
what does he mean believes I'll be
honest uh it wasn't me observing uh
sorry what so yeah the whole Prius
missed the simple 1v2 meme
isn't technically
true we were just sitting on the
sidelines
and pgl were observing cologne playoffs
we did group stages and pgl did playoffs
and so that's when the kill happened
because I have video I was reporting the
casters I want to see what the guys look
like when casting and on big players and
so I recorded them it'd be weird if I
had a video with the casters doing the
job and me at the same time observing
I've never really told anyone that it
wasn't me
uh but I I try to keep that I guess at
Prius you know simple me too like I
think the meme is is more fun than
people actually finding out that it
wasn't me the question of course
is why like if priest didn't actually
miss the play then
why take the fall for it always for the
laws I don't I don't care if someone
actually you know thinks I missed it
I'll provide proof that it wasn't me if
if they need proof that it wasn't me uh
but it's definitely more fun to
play with it I just don't like what
people are serious about it just like I
was telling you about one where like he
goes yeah well expected from the guy
that you know actually missed the same
way too and I never responded like hey
but it wasn't me the meme has even
carried over to valorant where Prius is
roasted regularly for just about
anything the attack dogs thing is pretty
funny Sapphire shared like a tweet of
like a graph of like when The Observers
are most appreciated and it's because of
you know Terex attack dogs that are just
brutal sometimes and it's not even like
us sometimes
like sometimes our Observer our
cinematic Observer will switch off
and caption it out
um but he didn't realize that there was
another action going on on the main POV
and so it's like
yeah but it's it's not something you can
control unfortunately where am I where
the my Observer move me bro
wait what
I think the Observer is sleeping Prius
hold on it might not be Prius who knows
a suit I always get so much but that's
okay because aside from the fact that
it's mostly in good fun the memeing that
Prius endures is in service of a greater
cause to get Esports fans talking about
observing sure they might be poking fun
at Prius but as the old adage goes any
press is good press it gives observers
like a name with cs go directly like
interacting with me on Twitter and like
all the community figures directly
interacting with me and The Observers it
puts like a face to the name and puts us
like oh this guy oh he he controls the
camera oh like
so you know you have to explain to them
and it's just it's so interesting to
it it puts the observing on the map
Prius might forever be falsely
remembered as the guy who missed CS goes
sickest play
but it is a burden that he's willing to
Bear because when all is said and done
it's a net positive for him the Cs go
community and The Unsung art of
observing as a whole and that that helps
a lot with you know my job it helps a
lot with you know other people wanting
to get involved in a job like I joked
about there's 12 observers you know that
one of BCS you know Surfers I now get
daily messages
of about how to become an observer and
keep in mind it wasn't all that without
the missing of the play we wouldn't have
been gifted with bardolph and ddk's now
iconic reaction to it simple I don't
know man if he just comes in with that
so even if he has to endure a
never-ending barrage of memes for
something that he's not actually guilty
of
as far as Prius is concerned in the end
it's worth it everyone at ESL knows it
wasn't me of course
uh and everyone a blast as it wasn't me
and so I think I think it's a fine meme
of the stomach and I'm actually kind of
glad I started
I loved this sound up around if you
heard in the interview but it's actually
fantastic it's so funny when he talks
about League
the community may play League of Legends
and I just I just didn't I just didn't
like it I just thought it was the worst
game ever I despised it like he just
literally
came out of nowhere like I was dying I
was trying not to laugh because I hadn't
muted myself in the interview and I was
trying not to laugh it was
really funny